yeah so actually that brings in an
interesting point like what what's the
delimitation between your business life
and your personal life and in can are
from your space are people using
different calendars like how like what
how's that work out yeah it's a it's I
think one of the interesting challenges
of our time in general is that the line
between work and home has in many cases
for the knowledge worker evaporated yeah
but you know I think more to the better
right I think that that is actually a
good thing that I am in some ways more
in control than ever between what I'm
doing at any given time and if I need to
get work done at a particular time
that's great if I need to you know be
with my family that's great you know I
routinely and I know I'm fortunate in
this way in the IBM culture but if i
want to go spend an hour in my
daughter's classroom you know in her
third grade class during the workday
that that's fine right because i'm going
to be on calls with China and India and
Japan at ten o'clock 11 o'clock at night
my iPad or my blackberry has everything
I need or business or work or personal
sorry all of one plays so for me I'm a
10-1 calendar I have an overlay of that
that's my 8 year olds calendar though
right so you know but I'm managing a
calendar for any girl but moms and dads
everywhere have always done that's been
on the kitchen refrigerator and instead
now it's on you know Google or Yahoo or
some service like that it's electronic
yeah but that but that marriage is
incredibly powerful and I think it's
important you know whether whether what
it allows is things like my wife now I
don't have to send her my travel
itineraries anymore they're on tripit so
I just made her a reader of all my stuff
on tripit she knows what hotels I mean
what flights I'm on there's no questions
anymore I don't make mistakes anymore oh
no that's not the flight i'm on i typed
up a number wrong whatever it's all it's
all there in electronic form so yeah is
that my work life is that my personal
it's what I do
yeah and if you look at your role
specifically in IBM you know IBM is
known to be one of the leaders when it
comes to the larger enterprises and so
on and so what are the privacy concerns
of exactly what you talked about like
the balancing the private life corporate
life people are meeting in one calendar
they want to share it outside their
enterprise yeah what are what our
companies saying about this yeah and
there's still a lot of companies that we
sell to that you know you put up a
screenshot of a user's profile and
tumble and they go oh wait a second
that's got all my stuff on right I had
that reaction when I did a demo of
tumble and one of our conferences in May
and so I started doing my demos now
logged out of tumble and I eventually
look in right but so there's still a lot
of companies that are real paranoid
about where is this data going
especially remote devices blackberries
and iphones in that and it's an
interesting issue because if i am in a
company that you know decides one day I
don't need you know I'm not needed
anymore they could do a remote wipe my
personal data is probably on that device
to it I just I had no shot to get to it
right so there's all sorts of
interesting implications of who owns my
deed an email I get that right Nelly
okay fine I left the company you want
your email back no problem but the
calendar the calendar is kind of like me
right that's it me as an individual so
there's definitely some issues that
haven't really been worked through yet
and that people are going to struggle
with how do you think it's going to
evolve I think that I think having
aggregation points I think having
redundant data I mean you know that's
greatly can wipe my blackberry but it's
it's October all right now so I know
that I've got a copy there and just hope
that know if it was six and overwrites
it tomorrow but um I think we're done in
data I think overlays you know
publishing through caldav and things
like that some of which we have to catch
up on admittedly you know give people
some ability to open their own data
around their own self and overlay that
mariya with their professional
environment
but I think that lines very very blurry
and I don't expect we're going to move
to any point of clarity I think the
nature nature of work has changed so
much that trying to keep your work life
and your personal life completely
separate and secure from each other in
2015 we won't even think about that
concept interesting and so if you look
at you know back when it was
client-server you've had you know your
company have your your data on their
server and then then it started to
migrate towards the web given right what
were some of the privacy concerns back
when it started and actually there's
still nice tile area yeah but but okay
so so what were the challenges and some
of them have already been brought down
like if you look at Salesforce I think
you know sales force has done a good job
in educating people that the cloud is is
safe right yeah i mean we're at a point
where not everybody's bought it right we
did a survey with one of our resellers
600 people filled it out in the last few
weeks more than half the participants in
the survey said we'll never do anything
in the plot you know yeah it's 2010
right so are those banks or those
government agencies are those insurance
companies are they manufacturing you
know I don't I haven't gone looked at
that data yet but half of them just said
no no clock period but the other half
were like we had clouds an inflection
point great opportunity for us we want
to do more and it's the pervasive access
it's the fixed cost of operation I mean
there's all that all those benefits so I
think there are still many many issues
that companies need to get their heads
around okay my data is going to live
somewhere else and that's okay but what
data is it that's going to be okay if it
lives out there we look at in the email
world in that archiving space right
there is the traditional on-premise you
know heavy-duty IBM common store kind of
content management stuff that is really
secure and really well managed and then
there's in the cloud archiving providers
like the Sounion who are just treating
it like any other data feed that's going
to go live on an amazon server and with
the right passwords and other
authentication you're going to get
to it so it's a risk factor of it and a
lot of companies that are you know
risk-averse are not going to go there a
lot of companies that say the trade-offs
are worth then like many decisions about
sort of web 20 in general right now are
going to say this is okay for us we know
the risks the users in control or we as
an entity or still in control enough
that this is okay but you still find
plenty of people that in 2010 aren't
ready to be on Facebook and ready to be
on linkedin are ready to be on Twitter
those are the kind of people that
probably are still not ready to have the
corporate data living out of the club on
the other hand there is sales force
there is Google Apps there is lotus live
you know and companies are hungry for
that kind of you know SAS business model
and are willing to accept the risk to
get the benefit of predictable service
always upgrading fixed costs and you
know sort of all the other benefits so I
think privacy is concerned but I think
there's a lot of other uses to the mex
you know I don't know if it's actually a
conversation from the camera so it's
actually just a question I have as well
so if you want to have that conversation
offline is you know like if you look at
the price point right the price point
for a lotus lotus live notes for example
five dollars per user per month yep it's
fairly cheap yep for what people used to
pay 500 bucks for our perpetual license
right which also means that for a
company like IBM the ER for Lotus the
revenues will eventually see a price
please maybe and that's my point like my
question over my point is what how will
you be able to maintain as a corporation
the level of revenue and profit that you
were going after and maybe it's a lot of
conversation for this book actually a
question I want to take your brain on
yeah I can keep I'll tell you what
microsoft says yeah how do you put a
camera microsoft says that be poss is a
play for bigger share of wallet that
they actually think they're going to
generate more revenue than they do off
of license sales because they have now a
fixed annuity coming in every month for
every
serve whether they were on software
assurance or not and that the more
services they have in the cloud the more
revenue they generate per user I look at
the cloud more as a choices delivery
model so for me I'm not I'm not looking
at it as a revenue maximization scheme
but once the customer has bought a
perpetual license for notes the annuity
revenue is twenty-six percent right a
pretty industry standard kind of a thing
what they'll pay us for Lotus live is
probably about the same as what they
were paying in annuity revenue so it
does come down to the same kind of
attitude as Microsoft's is if I add to
Lotus life a meetings and collaboration
and the file sharing and you know a
number of other services the revenue to
IBM will will certainly increase over
time the profitability parts partner but
if you look at SAS companies and this is
probably what you're asking you have to
look at cost as being an area where
you're constantly optimizing right so
you know what can we do to get 10 sets a
user a month operational costs out this
month what are we going to do to knock
another fifteen cents out when we look
at companies in the SAS space the ones
that are doing well financially have not
just figured out a revenue equation
they've figured out a cost equation and
in software I never really had to think
about that right i had to set a fixed
cost to build a version of the product
and that was in my variable cost was 0
basically zero yeah now i have variable
cost ok so in your mind I mean you
briefly talked about you know this these
are the things that project Vulcan is
working on but in your mind what is the
calendar with huge
so I think the calendar of the future
has to in some ways disappear into the
background I don't know how and when
that happens but it has to no longer be
a now I go to my calendar and think
about calendaring I have to really get
to a place where it is seamlessly woven
into the other tasks that I'm doing with
the analysts looked called contextual
collaboration the calendar hasn't quite
come to contextual collaboration part of
it is the PDA or mobile device mentality
of okay let me just check my calendar do
I have that time available but you know
in a in an iPad or you know that kind of
device configuration it's I have to stop
what I'm doing click the big butt and go
over to my calendar get to the data that
I'm looking there's like 17 steps to go
be productive in a calendar whereas it
should be looking at a document and now
I need to know if on July eighteenth I
can do something with that document so
our thinking and project Vulcan and lots
of other people's thinking and you know
some of the projects we see right now is
how do you get away from that task
orientation and much more to a process
orientation or a contextual orientation
I don't know I've worked with calendar
it for what did we say in 15 16 years
and it hasn't happened yet I think there
will still because of the nature of the
calendar driving my activity still be a
discrete activity but it should get more
integrated into other things and then I
think the other question that really has
to be answered is how much sharing do I
end up doing again most companies still
people don't make their calendar wide
open they don't let people see what
they're working on and there has to be a
way to make that socially acceptable in
the company just like it has been share
my documents and share my knowledge
right because I mean we've gone down
this curve and collaboration in general
when we started shipping nodes 20 years
ago we had to teach companies why it
would be good to share the information
that everybody had in a company most
companies were my knowledge is my value
to the company
and so our first notes customers
actually had to put incentive programs
in place for humans to get compensated
for putting stuff in the notes databases
it's kind of the same with calendars I
still don't really feel comfortable
telling people what am i spending my
time on every day my own staff though
probably could really benefit from
seeing which customers I'm meeting or
what projects I've spent choosing to
spend my time on what are my priorities
more than a once-a-month staff meeting
whatever so there's still a cultural
barrier and I see that in lots of our
customers and I think it just stems from
the personal nature of Calgary and
that's probably the last piece that i
would say kind of in the future we still
have two addresses in industry i get as
a vendor or feature request for calendar
than any other part of our messaging and
collaboration because calendaring is an
intensely personal activity i want to
operate is different than how the next
person wants to operate and it's
different in japan and it's different in
israel and it's different in germany and
you know we build a horizontal product
right so you know we almost ship notes
version 8 without the ability to see the
week number in the notes aid calendar
and at the last minute I basically
stopped the chef because we hadn't put
that feature in and we had plan to put
it in later I said you can't ship a
calendar without week number support for
the German market because they drive
events around well in week 17 we're
going to do X or in Japan they really
want a few calendars horizontally and
not vertically because of the cultural
hierarchy within the country or in you
know Hebrew it's gotta really go right
to left and the work day has to the work
week has to start on Sunday not on
Monday and you know so the feature
requests are constant because there are
cultural differences around the world
and every individual has a feeling of
how they want to do it and then the
other impact is every new device that
comes out has a different way of
calendaring and so people want to borrow
the best at worst for me right now my
big inflection point is as I keep
looking at at my iPad sitting over there
great calendar system Apple as always
has done a really great job at usability
but guess what there's no free time
search there's no ability to counter
proposed there's no ability to delegate
a meaning to somebody else I can't even
send comments in if I accept a meeting
there's nothing it's yes no maybe so
really great interface but because
they've narrowed the scope so much I
what they're going to actually try to
accomplish of course if I would